hey leute
den extra heute mit meinem neuen
europäer aus gefahren an den schönsten
ort also die ich von berlin aus
erreichen kann wenn ich bisher nur
schlafen wird und trotzdem noch den dreh
auf die kette kriegen will deswegen sag
ich jetzt
du schönes brandenburg und warum nehme
ich diese harte entbehrungsreiche reise
von 50 minuten auch nicht wegen diesen
becher habe ich extra aufgehoben vom
letzten dreh wir hatten da catering
inklusive coffee to go und dann hab ich
mir im becher geschnappt firma einen
jahresrückblick und wilder beim gehen
daraus trinken alles auf anfang action
kameraleute ich live aus dem kiosk mit
dem kaffeebecher in der hand card
abbruch unruhe am set ich weiß nicht was
los ist gucke mir runter ich trage eine
hose glück gehabt der regisseur renz zu
mir und sagte wenn du dir einen
shitstorm ersparen willst nimm kein
einwegbecher erreicht man eine
glasflasche mit wasser und ich denke
aber hier am set stehen 100 pappbecher
wer es mit plastikgeschirr ist es nicht
verloren und dann erinnere ich mich wie
wenig spaß das macht wenn du dir echt
mühe gegeben hassen lustiges und
informatives video zu machen und das
einzige was danach darunter steht sind
kommentare von malte 67 der in
großbuchstaben schreibt system liege
immer schön gegen autofahrer hätten aber
denselben einwegbecher benutzen und dann
habe ich halt die flasche genommen aber
damit ist jetzt schluss nimmt das x t60
gehen wir das thema noch frontal an
einwegbecher reden wir darüber also die
kollegen von der anstalt mehr externe
tafel hingestellt vielen dank liebe
grüße an die kollegen einwegbecher
allein in deutschland werden pro jahr
2,8 milliarden dieser becher verbraucht
2,8 milliarden das sind 7,6 millionen
becher pro tag allein
43.000 bäume werden jedes jahr
verbraucht nur damit typen wie ich
morgens ohne thermoskanne aus dem haus
gehen können
hast du wirst auch für
kaffeespezialitäten latte macchiato
cappuccino alles im praktischen coffee
to go ein wenig ja also holt sich immer
super gerne es gab nur ein bisschen
ungünstig wenn man auf einwegbecher
verzichten würde würde man nicht nur 2,8
milliarden becher sparen sondern 40.000
tonnen abfall
22.000 tonnen rohöl die man allein für
deckel und beschichtung braucht und man
würde
87.000 tonnen co2 sparen ist doch der
wahnsinn oder 87.000 tonnen
lässt sich jetzt nicht an dir
also na ja wohl ja es liegt alles liegt
an ihm muss man ehrlicherweise sagen
also also es liegt dann ja also okay
erzählt er ich habe verstanden es liegt
an uns die cannes leuten die so wegwerf
becher benutzen ja ich hab's verstanden
okay so aber dann bleiben wir doch mal
bei den 87.000 tonnen co2 ich habe da
auch mal was vorbereitet
achtung aufgepasst
herzlich willkommen so ge aufs ganze
jetzt
sind sie gefragt ja genau sich hier
meine damen und herren achtung wie viel
co2 stößt deutschland in einem jahr
insgesamt aus was für nervenkitzel mein
gott sind es vielleicht 3b und oder doch
wieder runter und oder
20 millionen sind es mehr sind es
weniger ist das spannend die zeit ist
abgelaufen ist alles falsch wenn man
immer lohnen es sind stolze
680 milliarden tonnen im jahr roman nur
die erste ich weiß nicht warum
vielleicht war es das glitzer sakko da
übertreibst du einfach gern ein bisschen
und mit ein bisschen meine ich viel es
sind natürlich nicht 680 milliarden
tonnen sondern 680 millionen tonnen
stellt euch also bitte 30 weniger vor
und den ballon der gleichkommt um den
faktor 10 kleiner
so ist es richtig jetzt gehts weiter
sorry fielen neben der geige wenn diese
erbse die co2 einsparungen durch die
ausschließliche nutzung von
mehrwegbechern ist dann ist dieser
belong der gesamtausstoß von
kohlendioxid in deutschland
und jetzt licht aus wir müssen strom
sparen dann reden wir nochmal ein
shitstorm ich sage euch jetzt mal wo wir
stehen der un-generalsekretär antonio
ätherisch nennt den letzten klimabericht
ein dokument der schande dokument der
schande das habe ich zuletzt gelesen und
hanna mathearbeit von mir und ähnlich
hoffnungslos wie mein mathelehrer klingt
der generalsekretär er sagt der
klimabericht ist ein katalog der leeren
versprechen die die weichen klar in
richtung einer unbewohnbaren erde
stellen buck münster gar keine hoffnung
doch ein bisschen laut hans joachim
schellnhuber einem der renommiertesten
klimaforscher der welt besteht noch
immer eine
28 prozentige wahrscheinlichkeit dass
wir eine erderwärmung über zwei grad
verhindern können und jetzt könnte man
sagen war 20 prozent das ist ja nicht so
viel lohnt sich das denn überhaupt was
zu tun schönes bild vom schellnhuber
wenn man ein schwer krankes kind zu
hause hat und der arzt sagt es sieht
schlecht aus aber wir haben eine neue
therapie mit einer
erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit von 20 prozent
da wird man auch sagen probieren wir es
20 prozent
das ist immer ein gutes drittel liebe
grüße an der stelle an herrn kern meinen
ehemaligen mathelehrer klar ist aber
auch hier geht es nicht um dich und
deine hafer milch was wir brauchen ist
ein kompletter systemwandel sagen nicht
nur linksextremistische kapitalismus
kritiker sondern auch der weltklimarat
rede ist von einem weltweiten und
wirtschaftlichen strukturwandel von
einer systematischen transformation
kleines beispiel stell dir einen großen
waldbrand vor und auf der einen seite
löschen leute mit wasser und auf der
anderen seite stehen leute mit
ölschläuchen das löschen bringt nichts
wenn man nicht aufhört öl ins feuer zu
gießen ohne die industrie können die
ganze sache komplett vergessen aber die
versucht uns die verantwortung für die
bewältigung der klimakrise zuzuschieben
beispiel co2 fußabdruck der gibt an wie
viel jeder und jede einzelne an
kohlendioxid freisetzt diesen begriff
hat der ölkonzern bp groß gemacht weil
sie genau wissen wenn jeder einzelne
sich schuldig fühlt kommt niemand darauf
dass die carbon industrie und deren
große lobby in die politik das
hauptproblem ist und so schieben wir uns
gegenseitig die schuld in die schuhe das
bindet unsere kräfte und die carbon
industrie freut sich drüber wir
beschäftigen uns damit uns moralisch
überlegen zu fühlen wenn wir gutes tun
und andere als klimasünder runter zu
machen das allein aber macht noch nichts
besser und wer kann schon genau sehen ob
der andere oder die andere wirklich
gerade schlecht es für die umwelt macht
da sitzt jemand in einem suv und ihr
denkt umwelt verpestet aber vielleicht
ist die person noch nie geflogen gerade
auf dem weg zu einer konferenz auf der
sie eine neue technologie vorstellt die
weltmeere vollständig reinigen kann kann
ja sein und ganz ehrlich hast du nicht
schon mal ein billiges t shirt
geglaubten döner gegessen oder bisschen
urlaub geflogen wer unschuldig ist
werfen den ersten kaffee becher
andere bewerten die man nicht kennt ist
wie im film bewerten bei dem man nur ein
bild gesehen hat also systemwandel das
klingt abstrakt aber es gibt sehr
konkrete lösungen erstens allein das
bauen mit stahl und beton ist für 40
prozent aller co2 emissionen weltweit
verantwortlich und die idee ist einfach
bau mit holz und das krasse ist weil
bäume co2 speicher sind ist bauholz
nicht nur klimaneutral sondern klima
positiv heißt mit dieser abzubauen
entziehen der atmosphäre co2 zweitens
subventionen streichen 2018 sind in
deutschland insgesamt
65,4 milliarden euro an
umweltschädlichen wirkenden subventionen
ausgezahlt worden es gibt zum beispiel
immer noch das dienstwagenprivileg also
wenn du dir einen richtig fetten benz
als firmenwagen holes unterstützt
herstatt dass dieses gegenteil vom
klimaschutz kostet uns richtig viel geld
mehr als drei milliarden euro jedes jahr
allein wenn man das streicht könnte man
jeden sommer für drei monate das neun
euro ticket einführen die politik hätte
nicht nur gelegenheit all diese gelder
zu stoppen die könnte auch sagen ey wir
unterstützen nur noch dinge die aktiv
neues co2 verhindern warum zb wird
regelmäßig der kauf von autos gefördert
aber fast nie der kauf von fahrrädern
was uns stattdessen als lösung präsent
hier wird weltrettung durch konsum die
idee ist alle können doch einfach
kritische verbraucher werden die öko
jeans kaufen fairtrade spargelschäler
regionale butter dhg acht stunden am tag
arbeiten und danach hätte bitte noch
zwei stunden die welt am kühlregal und
deswegen jetzt willkommen zum großen
alltags quiz finde ich vielen dank ein
lebensmittel das kein gift für die
planeten ist hier vielen dank haben wir
erstmal magen und hier haben wir butter
dass er erst mal nichts schlechtes würde
ich sagen wir haben was ist der preis
für die umwelt für ein kilo braucht man
23 8 kilo co2 werden da freigesetzt das
ist der klimakiller nummer eins
verrücktes spiel wer hätte das gedacht
gut aber hier ist ja gut dass jetzt auch
egal nuss nougat creme das ist vegan
kann keiner was dagegen haben oder was
ist da der preis so abholzung des
regenwalds durch palmöl okay aber ihr
das ist das sogar vegan das ist eine
avocado das kenne ich das ist bio
versteckt sich hier unser gewinner pro
kilo 1000 liter wasser einsatz notwendig
ja gut aber das ist man ja sagen so gibt
es hier irgendwas dass ich erster kam
mit dem ich nicht die welt in brand
setzte
[Musik]
keine schlangengurken sind salatgurken
die kann ich jetzt essen ja klasse danke
zehn kilo bitte davon
die eigentliche frage ist doch wieso
geht hat dass die industrie dinge
produziert bei denen man weiß dass wir
dazu beitragen das leben derer die jetzt
20 sind zu ruinieren es ist verpönt
während der schwangerschaft zu rauchen
aber wenn das kind erst mal draußen ist
dürfen alle nach herzenslust hessen zu
und ruinieren ich will mich aber gar
nicht jeden tag aufs neue gegen den
klimawandel entscheiden müssen ich will
dass das gar nicht geht zum beispiel
massentierhaltung krasse subventionen
fürs fliegen und 0 preiswerte
alternativen dazu ich möchte dass die
politik die entscheidung trifft die ich
nicht jeden tag treffen kann ich will
wählen weniger wahl zu haben klingt
erstmal paradox aber was ist das denn
auch viele komische wahl klimaschädlich
zu handeln als würde ein mal am tag
jemand bei ihm klingeln und sagen wollen
wir heute ihre kinder vergiften niemand
käme darauf dass freiheit zu nennen was
ich meine ist ich will fragen müssen
entschuldigung haben sie auch was mit
fleisch denn wer sich in deutschland
vegan ernährt reduziert seine
treibhausgase und bis zu zwei tonnen und
die gute nachricht ist pommes ist vegan
ich will mich selber fragen dürfen darum
nehme ich das teure flugzeug wo es doch
auch eine billige baden gibt die gut und
pünktlich ist und brauche ich wirklich
ein haus aus beton okay das ist super
komische frage aber wir wissen was ich
meine gleichzeitig kann aber doch jeder
von uns natürlich auch individuell jetzt
schauen was tun ja aktuelle studien
zeigen dass umweltbewusstes handeln ein
unterschied macht wer weniger fliegt und
darüber spricht sorgt dafür dass sich
gesellschaftliche normen verschieben
wenn ihr jetzt schon viele sachen
schafft von dem ich viele nicht
hinkriege das finde ich mega
aber wenn wir politik und wirtschaft
nicht dazu zwingen viel mehr zu ändern
wird das nichts das mindeste ist keine
partei mehr wählen die so tut als könne
man so weiter machen wir jetzt nur ab
und an rauffmann hat meine bio banane
wir brauchen die umweltverbände und wir
müssen auch diese kag demos hilft ja
nichts ich will nicht so tun als wären
die mega geil die sind meistens am
wochenende irgendwer hinter einem brüllt
zu laut und dann steht er immer sohn
mike mit dreadlocks auf der bühne und
lädt alle ein nächsten mittwoch zum
slacklinen gegen nazis zu kommen aber es
soll ja auch kein vergnügen sein es soll
so sein dass sich alle in der politik
denken krass dass so viele menschen
diese tortur auf sich nehmen nur um uns
zu sagen dass wir scheiße bauen ich
komme auch bevor sie einen schutzraum
geht keine sorge ich komme mit
mehrwegbecher
[Musik]
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
mime hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
scheiß und liegt - wollt dann abonniert
jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller